now let me blow your mind away and shock
you John's gospel is a spiritual gospel
that is meant to point to spiritual
truths now let me let me show you what I
mean okay watch
here get ready we got a lot man I
promise you're going to be blowing this
is your Good Friday message
Orthodox get ready prepare your hearts
for Friday okay watch here
John 4:10 to 14 Samaritan woman Jesus is
thirsty for physical water and asked the
Samaritan woman to draw some water out
of the well to give him to drink she's a
Samaritan woman two strikes Jews don't
like Samaritans and Jewish rabbis don't
address women and Jesus dressing her and
she goes you a Jew speak to me Jesus
answered and said to her if you knew the
gift of God and who it is who says to
you give me a
drink you would have asked him and he
would have given you living
water she said to him sir you have
nothing to draw with and the well is
deep where then do you get that living
water are you greater than our father
Jacob who gave us this well and drank of
it himself and his sons and his cattle
Jesus answer said to her everyone who
drinks of this water will thirst again
you're going to keep drinking physical
water but whoever drinks of the water
that I will give him will never thirst
ever but the water that I give will give
him will become in him a well of water
spring up to eternal life now remember
thirst in John is not just physical
thirst it's pointing to spiritual thirst
thirsting for God's love his presence
his fellowship and
communion John
6:35 you ready we're going to go
deeper John
635 Jesus said to them I am the bread of
life he overcomes to come he who comes
to me will never hunger and he who
believes in me will never thirst you
hunger for God and thirst for God his
presence and love and fellowship in
Christ you'll be satisfied because God's
presence will fill you okay so we got it
right John 7
37-39 now on the last day the great day
of the feast Jesus stood and cried out
saying if anyone is thirsty let him come
to me and drink He Who leaves in me as
the scripture said from this from his
innermost being will flows River flow
rivers of Living Water Holy Spirit
control my tongue rebuke Satan in the
name of Jesus For Your Glory father
rivers of Living Water but this he spoke
of the spirit you catch it living water
is the holy spirit filling you with his
presence uniting you and connecting you
to the father and the
son but this he spoke of the spirit whom
those who believed in him were going to
receive for the spirit was not yet given
because Jesus was not yet glorified now
you want to really go deep and get blown
away all right so now I've established
right you're listening I've established
thirst in John is spiritual it's not
just physical right now notice the words
of Our Lord
carefully watch here and I got to do
some
connections so I'm going to do some
connection
okay now watch here I got to do some
[Music]
connections watch here now let's see if
you guys are going to catch
it you don't need to speak in tongues
out the Holy Spirit don't let them lie
to you and deceive you and focus sister
John 19283 now notice the timing there's
nothing coincidental
after this Jesus knowing that all things
had already been finished notice when he
had now fulfilled all things and he
accomplished God's
will to die for our
sins in order to finish the scripture to
fulfill it said I am thirsty
h i just established from John's
gospel that the thirst here is not just
physical right and is it a coincidence
that Jesus says I am thirsty after
knowing he had now fulfilled the will of
God and dying on our behalf to pay our
debt coincidence or something deep watch
here watch here
A A if this doesn't make you cry I don't
know what
will now if we believe the gospels are
harmonious they don't
contradict they don't contradict that
means we have to take Matthew Mark Luke
and John and the crucifix scene and tie
in these words of Christ in a sequence
so here's the sequence after this Jesus
knowing that all things had already been
finished in order to finish the
scripture said I am thirsty now they
misunderstood him a Jar full of sour
wine was standing there so they put a
sponge full of the sour wine upon a
branch of isip and brought it up to his
mouth now notice therefore when Jesus
received the sour he said it is finished
and bowing his head he gave gave up his
Spirit now watch I forgot to add
this watch
here now here's the sequence I believe
this happened after this Jesus knowing
that all things had already been
finished in order to finish the
scripture he said I am thirsty after
saying this Jesus said these words and
about the ninth hour Jesus cried out
with a loud voice saying
e that is my God my God why have you
forsaken me meaning now now that he knew
everything's finished now he cries out
to God it is done it is now time to come
to my
deliverance and God answered and then
when the darkness disappeared he then
says it is finished bowing his head he
gave up his Spirit now Luke then tells
us the exact words he said right when
his Spirit left his body Luke 23:46 and
Jesus cried out with a loud voice father
into your hand hands I commit my spirit
having said this he breathes last so
let's put the sequence
together Jesus
says I
thirst then he says my God my God why
have you forsaken
me
signal come to my Aid all things have
been accomplished it's time to deliver
me then father I'm sorry then he
says it is finished because God hears
his prayer when the darkness is removed
and he says father into your hands I
commit my spirit now with all that said
if you're listening you're not confused
right why did Jesus say he thirsts now
let's see because now that he knew all
things are accomplished I thirst this is
what he was thirsting for
watch Psalm 42: 1 want two As the deer
pants for the water Brooks so my soul
pants for you oh God my soul thirst for
God for the Living God When shall I come
and before appear before God that's what
he's saying father I thirst to be with
you in glory
again because I've accomplished all
things time for me to come home see
every time I think about it I almost
break down and cry
and there's a song as the dear see
ABA see it's going to hit me in my heart
I have accomplished
it time for me to come home to be with
you in glory alongside of you and you
know what the father says you know what
the father's answer
is about to cry man woo when the father
removed the darkness you know what the
answer was yes son
time to come
home time to come
home that's why he says father into your
hands I commit my spirit so now there's
a process before he goes and he goes and
he brings out the souls in Abraham's
bosom then he comes to life in his
physical flesh to assure us that God
heard him then he
returns you understand now how deep your
Bible
is so when the father removes the
darkness you know what the answer is now
here here Psalm 63
verse1 oh God you are my God and what
did he cry out on the cross my God my
god father you are my God I shall seek
you earnestly so what David has
experienced is fulfill perfectly
completely in Jesus the greater David my
soul thirst for you my flesh yearns for
you why because I'm living in a world
that is dry and without water this
Fallen World and it's not my
home you understand his cry prayer so in
other words if you're listening if
you're listening not being distracted if
you're
listening this is basically what's
taking place he's basically crying out
to the father
ABA see whenever I think about it it
moves me because this is true this
happen this is real guys this is real
the Lord uted these words it's real
ABA it's time for me to come
home this world is empty and dead and
I've came to redeem it but it's not my
world it's not my home my home is to be
with you alongside of you in glory until
I return and change this Earth it's time
for me to come home ABA I've done it
there's nothing left and when the father
removes the
darkness father removes the darkness you
know what the answer was this is the
father saying
son you have done all things
well you have accomplished the
Redemption of the world time to come
home come home son come
home come home where the angels will
know who you are and understand your
worth and will value and cherish you
and this is why when it says when he
says
here watch
here therefore when Jesus had received
the S he said it is
finished he's echoing Psalm
22:31 they will come and will declare it
his righteousness to all people be born
that he has done it it is finished it is
completed because he has done it he has
come to my
you caught it now watch
here it is finished is another way of
saying he has done it it is finished it
is completed it is done cuz he has done
it it is done because he has done
it you caught it
now do you see how glorious of a prayer
that
is how glorious of a prayer that
is did it all make
sense Psalm 22 perfectly
fulfilled now doesn't it make you fall
more deeply madly in love with the
father and the Son and the Holy Spirit
and what they paid for our salvation